CNN
the news network it was it was well the
former News Network of CNN uh also
chimed in on the Biden grandchild
situation and of course yes they also
said that the real issue here is it's
being used by Republicans
you know this is
a story that is sad and disturbing on so
many levels
um yes it is political for a couple of
reasons
um number one yes Republicans are using
it and are going to take advantage of it
in a way that is
unfortunate inappropriate
number one it's Republicans that's the
real issue here guys number one because
this crackhead son of the
dementia-ridden president had a child
out of wedlock with some other chicken
now they don't want anything to do with
the child nor to use his last name or
anything but the number one issue is
that Republicans are gonna pounce on
that oh my God you people are
absolutely horrible and again the double
standard and the Trump Junior thing and
all that
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]